47 seconds of inescapable low goats
what's up with this movie stealing its
own tension by revealing a scene from
the back half of the film not only do we
now know this character at least makes
it that far but we have zero invested in
them yet because we don't even know who
he is 10 numbers for spots
I need a four-digit code if this guy
made it this far wouldn't he know not to
start putting in a code until he figured
out what the code was these rooms are
designed to kill you if you make the
wrong moves and at this point he should
know that somehow out of all the things
in this room this random rolled-up
poster in a box of many posters contains
the first big clue follow the light to
greener pastures yeah but that required
the room to knock the light over for him
I know we're in an escape room designed
by jigsaw but this is the only room in
the movie that requires the killing
mechanism to begin before the player is
directed where to go great great book
how green was my Valley cheek barren
love
oh sorry I thought we were yelling out
undeserving Oscar winners in case you
confused it for Chicago the musical this
is movie code for we knew the first 20
minutes of this movie would be boring it
so we began with something towards the
end of the story so you wouldn't pass
out Adams won't change while you watch
them kids pay attention in class because
every single time a movie character is
shown in class they learn something that
helps them out of a huge Jam later and
opening on Friday check out a guy I feel
free kid I really do for drama if that
is true then yours concept of a perfect
box can't exist if Zoey can spout all
this hey look I'm super smart
mumbo-jumbo you think she would also
know that the famous mathematicians name
is pronounced Euler duh so he was that
whole previous scene a dream or was she
having an actual hallucination then
later woke up from a nightmare we didn't
see if you're going to put in the effort
to foreshadow some character backstory
maybe don't make it so confusing also if
this is a dream this has got to be the
most normal dream ever committed to film
I mean she even dreams about walking
through her door and while a party rages
I wonder she got fired from Cobbs
inception company wait you guys aren't
doing it are you sniffing for sex
evidence this is one thing I hate about
movies with puzzles in them they spend
more time on the characters frustration
solving the puzzles than actually giving
the viewer a good idea of how the puzzle
is solved our universe is calm I guess
this means they sent out a ton of these
boxes and the ones who got the puzzle
solved and RSVP'd first got a
reservation or did they sent just to six
people hoping they'd all solve it in
RSVP and all be available on the same
day
amanda harbour height is 5 foot 40 new
math suggests that she's over 8 feet
tall
also this number at the bottom of the
license contains entirely too many 7 6 s
and threes to be anywhere near in real
mus guys buy me dinner first and then
they put a nametag on you what a
terrible date is that so they'll have a
crib note for what name to scream later
that night I'll sneak in a second he
knows which is setting up escape rooms
to kill people with trouble pass and
doesn't want any proof they exist after
the fact couldn't detect that this kid
had another phone nah man unfortunately
I can so I just have sex with adult
women to fill the time using the word
adult as a modifier in this sentence I
think this is the escape room roll
credit it could be anything anywhere
it's crazy to me that the guy who's been
in eighty thousand escape rooms in his
life looks under the table first and
inside the kitchen cabinets when there
are magazines and books everywhere in
this room that are more likely to
contain clues there are interesting
parallels between this movie and David
Fincher's the game for sure but this is
that pickup artists book by Neil Strauss
why not have the novel based on the
movie so we're looking for screws no no
okay that was the subject of Neil
stresses the game you're losing focus
moving 451 the problem with a lot of
these fake puzzles is that they often
aren't progressive meaning you don't
have to do one thing to unlock another
it's clever that each room is meant to
play into someone's backstory but the
way this room was designed you could
escape it without actually ever turning
the oven all she said that last time she
said it the exact same way same cadence
same tone this should not be a
revelation every single one of these
people wouldn't know that was a
recording the second time they heard it
or we could just break it off extinguish
it right yeah this is the one part of
this escape room that just doesn't make
any sense to me even though the room
gets dangerously hot there is never a
fire to put out until it's too late
yet this extinguisher holds a key to the
partition that leads to the phone call
about following all posted rules and the
only reason they use the extinguisher is
because they think they can break a tiny
lock with it I know me nose is evil and
doesn't care if they live or die but if
you're going to make a sport out of
their deaths at least give them a
logical reason to use the items in the
room okay if you can simply press down
on the coasters to make the secret door
open then why not stick the glasses on
the coasters and put the books on them
to weigh them down this is hard being
chivalrous to you no one here wants to
have sex with you damn shots fired this
is the type of guy who would insult your
prowess with women while you're burning
alive where all the water you
we supposed to do now yeah well in this
room could possibly way that last glass
down
could it be I don't know the books I
don't mean to be heavy-handed with this
but these people's intelligence is
weighing down the movie by the way I
refuse to believe this isn't enough
weight to lower the coaster
the first coaster Zowie pushed down went
down with a light press movie will have
you believe that Danny crawled through
this duct in four seconds when I'm not
having it not immersive even if this guy
has a good excuse for thinking it's
still all just a game
he has way too much trust in the
management of escape room companies
there's no signal and the fact that
Danny's snuck a phone into this escape
room never comes up again what was the
point of him sneaking in a phone if it
didn't become important later movie
doesn't know how to check off cell phone
correctly they all go down in history
that means something yes it's Rudolph
the clue is Rudolph and the fact that
not a single one of these morons had
that immediately spring to mind is
making it even more difficult to light
them
and the Slumdog Millionaire Award for
escaping a room based on prior life
experience goes to Ben man tennessee has
officially gone overboard by sticking
their don't drive drunk commercials in
the middle of Saw movies threw off this
is not only the easiest puzzle it's also
the most curious one in the entire movie
but was the danger could they have died
maybe the game makers are throwing a
curve ball out to that last one where
they nearly died but everybody will
think that everything's on the up-and-up
after this but what's the point of that
dumb question are we outside yeah it
really is a dumb question considering
unlike us you are seeing this room in 3d
space which means it should be plenty
obvious that you are staring at a
projection and not an endless Mountain
Vista yeah awesome but the door closed
and got barred shut two minutes ago so
are you saying that they could have
smashed through the windows back into
the disappointing escape room I want us
to fight over a limited resources not
gonna work this time okay this time what
do you mean this time you've been in two
rooms and neither of them asked the
players to share a limited resources
saya fishing Oh how'd you miss that
because it wasn't there before again I
know Minos is trying to kill these
people but the first room and this one
both contain clues found by sheer dumb
luck it just feels like I'm playing the
world's funnest game with the world's
meanest people twitter has climbed a
tree for the first time in my goddamn
life yeah that's incredible most people
can't do it if I haven't practiced and I
know you want to seem helpful but why
didn't you ask the others if they had
pre climbing experience before trying it
yourself something I'm good at
you mean you could stand over a hall and
hold a stick man no wonder this guy was
never promoted to a cash register job at
a grocery store he's a dick for
absolutely no reason this is the second
time he's just randomly dicta fired the
proceedings
but this demon some might say too deep
can we talk about the weight of water
and the structure of this building I'm
no aqua physicist but I know a bullet
amount of water in a building when I see
it
thanks a lot is the movie suggesting
that somehow the watchers knew that this
lighter would be tossed on the ice and
that Danny would be the one to pick it
up at this exact point or is this a
natural ice break that just happen to
take Danny and the lighter down either
way I'm suggesting the new title for the
movie be convenience room what was that
what happened daddy dude there's a giant
hole where the ice sheet was what do you
think happened you threw him the lighter
and somehow you're perfectly fine what
part of Ben wasn't anywhere near where
the ice broke is hard to understand
about this situation you guys get over
here put your hands on this ice just
laying on of hands idiocy may be the
dumbest thing and a movie full of dumb
things
sure body heat may be the best way to
melt it but your hands give off the
least amount of body heat on your body
any of these people would have frostbite
by the end of this nonsense
whoever is wearing the coat should have
that thing in the coat while breathing
on it and using their core temperature
to warm it up and there is at least one
would-be physicist here who would know
to do that also as no one ever heard of
friction why are your hands just sitting
there move them around find a course
leaf and use it like a dish scrubber do
the Hokey Pokey and turn it all about
anything beats this frozen seong and why
the hell are you melting it evenly on
every side just melt a hole straight to
the key these are the most stupid
randomly assembled stereotypes ever to
be randomly assembled and stereotyping
these guys all just douve into the room
from a door that was flat to the ground
where exactly is the door supposed to
have been considering the baseboard
lighting all the way around here guys
I've seen so many movies is this escape
room or is this that last Tomb Raider
movie where ex machina played Laura
crafts I guess it's a good thing that
they have the army chick and that she
didn't die in the previous puzzles so
that she can climb this impossible
upside down bar no one else could have
done this and I find that to be
tremendously poor sportsmanship on the
part of the psychotic escape room
creators yeah just try anything that
worked really well when you were in the
first room it's a giant signing puzzle
this room might be the best of the movie
and even it's too simple to solve an
obvious sliding puzzle produces a keypad
entry and gives you a handle to a door
look escape rooms are extremely popular
right now and there are plenty of
amazingly intricate puzzles to choose
from I'm not saying you have to make it
so complicated that it confuses the
audience I'm just saying I'd rather not
feel like the people you won't be to
root for are less likely to solve this
stuff than to qualify for the Darwin
Awards it might be tension but why are
you laughing asshole she still has to do
a lot
survive this just leave it you guys need
that eight-ball to exit the escape room
dude it then takes five cuts to show
True Blood throw a fastball too insecure
and I don't believe for one minute it
was successful but the movie is telling
me it is anyway yeah sure no my HBO
don't Amanda is dead we aren't survive a
little fittest you stop being a dick I
guess I'm going to sin human behavior
that happens all the time
but of all the people to ask another
person to stop being a dick it's this
guy
who's been a dick for no reason at least
three times in this movie Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer that's the song that
was playing when we crashed they made
these rooms for us the poetic nature of
the rooms loses a lot of steam when
certain players could die before they
even get to their personalize room
though what have been died in the first
room with the oven then he doesn't get
to the second room which related to him
sign language okay well this is great
for thought from me knows what happens
if Ben dies before this then you put
people in a puzzle they have no chance
of solving and you may be okay with that
but then I don't understand why you put
people in an escape room for your own
amusement if they can't possibly solve
the clues abstract concept that just
happens to start the movie turns out to
be super important later even though
it's an abstract concept and doesn't
actually apply cliche you got a lot of
other nerdy girl think she can convince
three dudes without any quantum physics
knowledge that she's right about
smashing the cameras when there's three
minutes left on the clock the movie
wants us to empathize with her character
because she's probably right but come on
around a nowhere idea what three minutes
left is too little too late says who did
I miss a part where they each found a
random Scrabble piece up their butts
that spelled out the proper heart rate
all this time the thinking was maybe if
we get someone's heart rate high enough
that'll solve the clue and now Jason
realizes that testing your limits might
mean finding a lower heart rate and I'm
sorry this is a bull puzzle it can be
interpreted both ways with no logical
way to the right answer finally it's
good to see the writers of the poems
from the original Jumanji are still
finding work also this room is yet
another one completely left a chance
what if only one of them had opened it
or others were still with them or they
thought to put some clothes on their
hands for grip or maybe even searched
around a while before they found the
hatch the drug trippy
is another curious addition to the
escape rooms theme of building a room
for each player
the only person this relates to was Ben
but he already had the reindeer room and
now I'm wondering which room was Mike's
he died in the last room when Jason
tried to speed up his heart rate his
story was that he survived a cave-in at
a mine none of the rooms had anything to
do with that and Danny totally missed
the poisonous gas room made for him
because he's dead
ah yes that classic and clever escape
room staple the thing hidden that you
find by randomly pounding on a wall gets
me every time
if you were hoping for a five-minute
vomit-inducing wrestling match between
two mostly unlikable characters where
you already know the outcome because
they showed you the survivor at the very
beginning of the movie well
congratulations
also I have to send the movie for using
strobe lights spinning floors and an
optical illusion paint job if for no
other reason then it just gave Marvel
more ideas on how to further obscure its
fight scenes in future movies and we're
back to the beginning of the movie and
not in a cool Lou and Davis got away
either more of a really annoying
Sisyphus kind of way if I'm being honest
she used it to breathe apparently even
though when we last saw her she had
collapsed on the floor after foaming at
the mouth and about this far from what
doesn't even appear to be the same mask
also why the hell is there a working
oxygen mask in this room also also she
takes up both of these orange suits with
one IV pole I mean those dudes are up
cold and I'm pretty sure she just hit
one of them a single time in the middle
of a back boy movie sure has kicked into
high yada-yada gear for these last few
escapes huh so he was being crushed but
just used a shield to hide in the
fireplace and that did the trick and her
head hit him on the idea that this kind
of thing could be going on at this level
for many years without anyone finding
out about it is almost more unbelievable
and upsetting than the fact that this
movie made more money than the Shawshank
Redemption a simple plan clue and
children of men combined that's right I
said clue initially had no survivors the
more I hear about this game the more I
realize that they did pick these
specific six people to open a puzzle box
in RSVP and escape room they didn't
throw out a thousand invitations hoping
to get a handful they targeted these
people so what happens if a few of them
don't want to play they wanted to know
if anything to do with it there was
really only one room that explored the
lock part and that was the billiards
room if this was some massive social
study you'd have thrown these people
into situations that would have required
more than 50% luck to survive like
eating at Denny's at the end of the
Kentucky
do you think the Hoss got surprised well
no because the results of the race will
be under review and despite the track
officials coming to the 100% correct
decision to disqualify the first-place
horse most of us will feel unsatisfied
because we'd rather see somebody cheap
win then another horse win on a
technicality also the winning horse
doesn't usually get strangled that's the
real point I wanted to make I understand
the puzzle maker has overridden the
system and realizes that Zoe is still
alive and that the game's master is now
part of the game but how the hell do you
know Ben is dead discount Russell Crowe
was barely mid strangled The Game Master
is now part of the game man's movie just
went from bananas to insane fruit salad
nothing like watching a movie with a
solid concept and mediocre execution
decide to shoot for finishing as b-movie
schlock Jesus Joey finish a game
telling oh I guess Ben was experiencing
the temporary unconsciousness that leads
to easy ex machina s' we haven't found
any evidence of the things you've
described none none no evidence of the
technological wiring or housing units
needed for the complex live broadcast no
evidence of the thousands of gallons of
water or reinforced walls to contain it
no evidence of the extreme amount of
power that would be needed to heat a
thousand square-foot oven or cool a
2,000 square foot freezer no evidence of
the giant sized custom elevator that had
to be built into the foundation of a
building no evidence about the web site
they had to go to it was simple minos
escape rooms calm did they wipe that
site out to the idea that this entire
operation could be wiped down in the
mirror hours since they escaped is the
biggest steaming pile of expositional
boat that I have ever had shoved down my
throat here's an extra 20 sins just for
thinking you could get away with that
also if you have the power to do all
that wouldn't it have been easier to
just send a couple of goons to kill Zoe
and Ben as they slowly limped out of the
building or is Minos slash Sony this
dedicated to making a sequel to the
escaper
well at least the movie knows window end
dammit we beat them at their own game
well technically you survived their game
to beat them at their own game you'd
have to trap them in a death trap with
you and then win so maybe slow down with
the bravado they're nerdy chick the
numbers aren't a pattern on the
staircase they're coordinates for an
unlisted industrial building in the
middle of Manhattan why would the secret
escape room company put out secret
coordinates for another building someone
could potentially investigate for any
reason I guess if the sequel comes
they'll say we wanted someone to figure
it out glad it was you Zoey
something something rich people not
content with five minutes of
conversational sequel baiting movie
decides it needs to show us a trial run
of the first scene from the next movie
to make sure we hit the credits
completely confused and unsatisfied
ledger sensitive flight information
based on this is the type of book I
can't stand in movies the omniscient
puppet master earlier Zoe told Ben two
weeks I'm going which means the puzzle
master knew she would figure out there
was something important about the Minos
logo and would fly to New York and he
obviously set up this airplane escape
room well before that despite knowing
about Zoe's fear of flying there are a
lot of answers I can accept based on
money and power but time and knowledge
are still factors and this requires
knowledge beyond human capabilities
I gotta get out of here what's in the
box it's the female orgasm that's the
myth
whoever did this us will let us freeze
it up if we don't get the key out of
that ice let's take some ice
I'll see well ignore this terrible drug
pretend it's not happening